alright Matthew is on the line Matthews
in Colorado hi Matthew welcome to Dave
Ramsey show hey Dave how you doing they
better than I deserve
how can I help ya so um my wife and I
are just starting out I'm only 22 years
old and we just paid off all of our
debts credit cards things like that it
wasn't too out of control I sold a lot
of a lot of stuff to pay it off but now
what we're looking at right now is I'd
like to start cosmetology school and
we're eligible for the Pell Grant but
that would still leave about ten
thousand dollars in student loans that
we potentially need to take out if she
pursues that and not my only concern is
that um I currently have any other debt
I have is a is a loan it's going to be
about five to six nine dollars a month
it's going to be coming out here in the
next month or two that you're familiar
with the military academy loans so my
concern is that we're on some minimal
income at the moment and as a way to
meet your heart attack on the mill here
I took the military room yeah which is
which is why like I said I've sold sold
and down I'm ready to how much do you
roll around so when I took the loan I
used it to buy a new car like a
knucklehead and then I I put the rest in
a Roth IRA so so it's 30 mm and don't
start coming out until the 10th of this
next month will be the first payment
then what's your household income so so
at the moment we're both just kind of
starting to get on our feet here at the
moment I'm making about $1,700 a month
with a pay increase in the next month or
two is what it's looking like and she's
pulling in about a thousand dollars a
month okay well I would like for her to
go to cosmetology cosmetology school
when you all can afford to pay cash for
it I would never in a thousand years
tell somebody take a student loan out
yeah ever yeah yeah I mean I just know
my only concern is you know it's just
she doesn't know she had a college
degree and because I didn't survive the
Academy I
I'm in position where I don't have to go
to school for about a semester but it's
a college degree rising you all to fail
or not fail throughout the scope of your
life if you choose as a part of your
career path to get some additional
education as you go along I think that's
fine but you pay cash for it yeah you do
not rationalize your butt off and get
yourself listen you've just been working
to get out of debt you feel trapped
right now by this stupid academy loan
and then you call up and say I want to
do more of that because it's so much fun
no it's not fun
no I'm being sarcastic okay no we don't
yeah you know so no I mean you can't
just decide to go do something and pay
for it
with a loan every time you do that it's
you're going to be broke your whole life
and so what you do is you lay down and
say okay what has to be true now we got
a work extra we're gonna be tight on the
budget we've got to take care of this
stupid Academy loan and we got to come
up with an additional ten thousand
dollars which if we save eight hundred
bucks a month for a year that's ten
thousand dollars yeah as opposed to and
someone else a honey mushroom yeah as
opposed to borrowing the money which
puts you right back in a mess and other
thing you want to do with cosmetology
school like any other school any other
academic any other trade school thing is
you shop you look at the different
schools that are available and the
different costs that are available and
you know when you're through you're
gonna be cutting hair if you're going to
cosmetology and no one is gonna come up
to the booth to get their hair cut and
go oh I can't I can't use you because
that's I don't like that I don't like
where you went to school you know yeah
it's been a long time since Dave had a
haircut okay Ellen here but I'd be back
what I got haircuts I never ask a single
person where they got their haircutting
license
so you go to the place that's the least
expensive and that gets you the basic
education to be able to function in that
world and you don't overpay for it in
other words that's part of the equation
might be that you find something that
you don't need an extra ten for you just
need an extra four four or something I
don't know
but I'm always always shopping education
is a funny thing people don't shop it
somehow they feel like the one place
that they found is the big deal and it's
just not so hope that helps you ma'am
thanks for the call